we're making miso salmon pasta so I have
a 12 year old sister who loves fun
pastas and since I'm home for the
weekend I made her this and because I'm
the coolest big sister I made sure she
got her macros so I use salmon to which
I then seasoned and pan fried until
crispy set aside in the same pan with
all that delicious residual flavor toast
up some scallion ends more garlic pepper
a few dollops of miso cream of mushroom
and then add in the reserved pasta water
broth cream parm and lots and lots of
lemon I brightened up mine with some
parsley more pepper and of course the
secret ingredient furikake so Julie if
you see this please save it and make it
for Mom okay love you bye